what relationship advice would you give
the youth what relationship advice like
romantic yeah come on you're what your
love you're what love what would you say
you know what this is what I would say
and I know this is probably what I I
tell this to my daughter that you are
the love of your life that's right and I
think that when you start with yourself
loving yourself creating boundaries
advocating for yourself being honest
with yourself not being so good that
you're not being honest you know
especially as a woman then I think
everything grows from there it is the
greatest seed you can plant in the world
to create great friendships and
relationships is To Love Yourself
there's nothing greater than a woman
that has confidence and this one had it
and uh We've created this relationship
that's just beautiful so we're just
thankful it's my dud